A class in ULM or in an object-oriented language, is a description of a similar
set of instances. Candidates for classes include domain objects,
roles, events, and interactions. In the previous lesson we learned how
to use nouns as a way of giving you ideas of what are good candidate classes.
In UML a class is denoted by a rectangle that is horizontally partitioned in to
three or more units. Actually, all but the first of those units is optional.
The particular units which are most commonly used, are the name, the attributes,
and the operations. And we'll be looking at all of those. In addition,
if you wish, you could have units that describe responsibilities, exceptions,
and so on. Here's and example of a UML class. There are three horizontally
partitioned units. The top one features the name of the particular class,
in this case it's window, it's the window class. In the middle is an area where
the attributes of that class are described. In this case, they're attributes for
the size of the window, the visibility, and other features. In the bottom
most of the three units is a description of the operations which a window object
can provide. In this case it can display, it can hide, and so on.